hey man you already know it's your boy
pamby rock man you can check out my
interview with my guy bootleg kev on the
bootleg calf podcast oh yeah
all right man look bullet cab show
special guest in here my guy yeah cerski
b rock man welcome brother oh yeah how
you doing bro just vibing bro how are
you i cannot complain brother i cannot
complain um i feel like it's been a
minute since we've done an interview
definitely pre-pandemic yeah it was a
while i like to point out during the
pandemic i sold you a ps5
that was clutch though bro i pulled up
like the day or two after the ps5
dropped to sell young blue a couple
and then you grabbed i think you grabbed
the ps5 and the xbox off me i'm like oh
i need both of them it was so random you
feel me real sick yeah it was such a
moment right super random man um
yo i wanna you know what i've been
wanting to ask you because i i feel like
you don't get enough flowers in terms of
your
influence on the current
generation and sound of where music is
do you feel the do you feel that's the
case as well yeah you know
i feel like you were kind of the first
dude i can kind of really remember at
least one of the first dudes that were
really
implementing i guess what we'll call
like
r and b [ __ ] but
from a street angle
where it was kind of blurring the lines
of hip-hop and r b like i really kind of
feel like you were
on the forefront of that man yeah i
ain't gonna lie like i came home in like
2013 2014
wasn't nobody really doing that [ __ ] and
i got rebooked again because i was just
[ __ ] around just yeah not doing what
i was supposed to do and i got locked up
again and that mix of that fetty wap
came out and [ __ ] i'm like oh [ __ ]
somebody
somebody about to come [ __ ] that wave up
that i had you heard me yeah but it was
like
when i still i still had to like i don't
i don't know when i before i got booked
it was like i had [ __ ] rolling already
like shows i had features people was
[ __ ] with my sound already and then i
got locked up for like nine months eight
months that [ __ ] was it was like i was
thinking like damn it's over like it's
gonna slow me down right there's another
[ __ ] i'm hearing this on the right i'm
like this other [ __ ] just came and he
on the same wave i was on you feel me
i'm like damn it's over
but that [ __ ] ain't stop nothing though
i mean i came home
[ __ ] was even way bigger than it was
when i was first originally out there
like hey lee was coming to [ __ ] with me
and everything i'm like i'm gonna pull
up you feel me that [ __ ] was different
and then i actually the person that
signed fetty wap was the person that
came to sign me orlando
mm-hmm so i was like
i'm thinking that the way it was gonna
be i'm thinking it was gonna be a little
awkward you feel me like damn this
[ __ ] he probably gonna think
like i'm trying to steal his sound and
[ __ ] and i've been doing this [ __ ] right
but this [ __ ] was the most genuine
[ __ ] ever when i first met him fetty
yeah i just heard such great things
about fetty fetty the goat man shout out
to fetty man he put me on a whole bunch
of game as far as like the music
industry like how how [ __ ] is going to
carry he put me on like he told me how a
whole bunch of rappers was going to be
before i even got to do it like and i
started noticing this [ __ ] like dance
[ __ ] cuddy put me on this [ __ ] a minute
ago you need to be really like trying to
leech off you
get will you get get what they call if
you get your clown and yeah that should
be weird yeah i feel like a lot of that
probably had to have happened to him
because i feel like at a certain point
in time for at least a year he was the
hottest thing moving hey [ __ ] it bro
because when he was opening for chris
brown on tour
people were more excited and i swear to
god because i was at the radio station
giving away tickets to the chris brown
fetty wap tour and everyone was calling
out they weren't asking for chris brown
they were like yo we want to go see
fetty wap and i'm like well you know
chris brown is going to be there too
they didn't care
so he like he he was a superstar for you
know 12 months maybe two years i mean it
was a great 12-month run he had that
craziest run but i do feel like you know
he was he's probably been in a position
as if you maybe where you notice like
maybe when you have a certain amount of
momentum behind you there's these
industry people
that come around when it's convenient or
when it's very beneficial to them but
maybe when your [ __ ] ain't as scorching
as it might have been like you really
realize oh this [ __ ] is fake as [ __ ] man
it'd be like you think a [ __ ] genuine
you think by listening to somebody music
they give you like a picture like thing
i think of this person like this and i
think this person like i hold him up
here because he'll be on that man you
meet these [ __ ] man they be
like who the [ __ ] write [ __ ] music you
feeling like the same person bro like
right it should be weird and they were
like i didn't help a lot of people
because i'm one of them people and i
still do i don't let that [ __ ] change me
i helped like when i had my run even
though like people used to tell me like
bro you shouldn't do this feature with
this person you shouldn't do this
feature with this person they ain't they
they just trying to use you i'm like bro
if i [ __ ] with somebody music i'm going
to do it
i'm not doing this [ __ ] for the money or
right i'm not doing this [ __ ] i don't
give a [ __ ] i'm just having fun that's
what i like to do yeah i like the [ __ ]
i'm going to do it you feel me so i gave
millions of features away i mean some
people would say arguably you probably
give away your biggest hooks to other
artists i literally one of those people
that like because at the time like my
lady wasn't really doing what i wanted
to do for my music and [ __ ] like they
was putting [ __ ] out but it wasn't like
having like a big push so if i come
across somebody that i know like they
label going hard for them right now
they're gonna probably i will give you a
whole like some [ __ ] that i already got
right and just give it to you just keep
me on it you feel me you know i've seen
the way you you're in the studio you're
very like
you know some artists you'll know
if there's not more where that came from
right real [ __ ] like
then there's those prolific writers
where you're like this [ __ ] is so easy
to somebody like yourself to get in and
just lay down ideas that are [ __ ]
crazy
it's like for you to like give a hook
away to somebody or to collaborate with
somebody and give up what you know some
people might be like yo man that he man
pnb rock gave up a crazy hook
there's so much more where that came
from
and that's not the case for everyone
a whole bunch of the hooks that you hear
that i gave to people be like it'd be a
story behind the type of [ __ ] like too
many years to call that black [ __ ]
mm-hmm i wrote that [ __ ] i was literally
about to get sentenced you know what i'm
saying like i'm in the [ __ ] box with
everybody that's about to go to see the
judge you feel me i'm like damn i didn't
give these [ __ ] too many years
already and i'm about to go get
sentenced again like this [ __ ]
you feel me so i'm thinking of this [ __ ]
while i'm about to go see the judge and
i'm making the melody everybody in there
like [ __ ] you singing like that [ __ ] so
hot
i let everybody in there here [ __ ]
like yo that [ __ ] deep bro like you
gotta go homie
like you gotta go crazy with that one
right there so i had this in the cup for
a minute i ain't never really dropped
that [ __ ] like when i came home because
i ain't had the right beat in my head i
heard like a specific beat right and i
could never find that [ __ ] you feel me
so i'm with this [ __ ] jay graham that's
my guy shout out to jay graham you
clutch yeah um i'm just in the cribby
highest [ __ ] this one i used to record
in a crate with him i'm just like bro
i'm trying to do this one hook that i
got bro can you please find a beat for
me you're like bro i can't i can't like
i can make a beat around it i'm like
well that [ __ ] ain't gonna work you feel
me like for me so you like just try like
just sing it and i'm gonna make the beat
around it i'm alright [ __ ] it i said put
the metronome on you know metronome was
like yeah
yeah i just sung the hook to that [ __ ]
you heard me cause i couldn't find no
beat bro he made the whole beat
surrounded that [ __ ] wow
[ __ ] bro i'm like damn the whole
and that's never that never happens
usually it's the beat starts or like a
loop and then you do it so so he made
the beat to your yeah under me that's
crazy we had this [ __ ] and i'm like dude
it's probably one of the biggest hooks
i've got right now you know what i'm
saying like i mean oh like me and
orlando
we like damn like what we gonna do with
this [ __ ] like we gotta like if we go
with if we go the way we wanna go it's
not gonna go how we wanted to go you
know what i'm saying because they're not
really pushing and pushing pushing for
my [ __ ]
so i'm like man who the next [ __ ] like
that you [ __ ] with this like could
tell this story for us you feel me like
because i i don't want this to be my
song at this point i want to yeah i want
to be big and i want this [ __ ] the world
to hear this [ __ ]
so you're like about to sign this kid
called that black bro you don't fight
like let me listen to this [ __ ] i listen
to this i'm like bro he perfect for this
[ __ ] like let's go meet this [ __ ] so i
linked up with kodak
and he got on that [ __ ] he was like
he was amazed he didn't really [ __ ] with
[ __ ] at this point like at this point
i feel like he's kind of always been
like that yeah he he was on somebody
else like
very interesting guy this [ __ ] yeah
yeah but when he heard my [ __ ]
he was like damn like this [ __ ]
different you feel me like i ain't never
i ain't no you was coming like that
and it was like we started [ __ ] with
each other on that level and we always
continued to make music after that
but that was like i got a lot of stories
like the everyday relationship that was
like my song you feel me like me in the
studio i mean we could tell me and every
man's me and wife and lucci in the
studio that's my session you from i just
caught him because i [ __ ] with his
music you showed me like we met in
atlanta i seen that he was in new york
while i was in new york i caught him
three deep and [ __ ] man for me you know
i turned that [ __ ] up from the rip he
played the bee i just went in you feel
me just went right in the booth like
this
and then he came and followed me and
then we just was going back and forth
back and forth it was supposed to be my
song you could tell by the way it was
structured like right
i actually had to take my verse and put
his second type [ __ ] but it was like
i already knew what they was gonna do
with that [ __ ] you feel me like they was
going heavy in the strip clubs and heavy
in the promotion in atlanta like as far
as like just paying dj's to play his
shot yeah you know i think it's a game
they they
you know i mean i'm saying their runs
not over but during that time
well they had a they had they got the
formula i was like at that point in time
they had a lot to prove too because
they had to show people that the rich
homie quan [ __ ] wasn't just a one-time
thing
you know what i'm saying so it was like
perfect timing i think oh yeah now i
just think you don't get enough love as
far as like if we think of everyone
who's like i mean really
where you kind of when you kind of
brought into the
you know industry obviously we talked
about fetty i think future was doing a
bit of that your [ __ ] is a little bit
different but
that's kind of where the game is now
i'll
at first i was a little sour you know
what i'm saying right like all these
little [ __ ] just coming taking
my [ __ ] and it's like
my situation was a little bit different
because i felt like my label just wasn't
like i ain't believing what i had going
on at the time but it's all these little
me is coming out and they
they stream they're going crazy they're
doing everything they're supposed to be
doing i'm like oh that's the week what
we doing with my [ __ ] for me and it's
like
y'all let these [ __ ] out run me now
cause i can't even drop as much as i
used to drop it just was like a
frustration thing on my label well i do
feel like too man like kind of what got
you here was being able to drop freely
heat up the streets
um
you know it's crazy because i i was in
the studio
like four or five months ago with you in
24 and you guys were working on a joint
project and it was like well how does
this how's this going to come out
because of your label real [ __ ] right no
shout out to 24 hours but like
um i just saw you commenting on snow the
products post she had said she posted
her recap yeah she was like no
management no distro no label
with and that's what i'm doing
maybe in 2022 that changes and you
commented no no
don't sign
keep going and you're somebody who's
been a part of the major label system
for what six seven years now when did
you first sign 2015. so yeah it's about
six years right
and you know you've shared your
frustrations with your label recently
earlier this year um
what what is it like where do you think
kind of the disconnect is
for p and b rock
and being on a major label
it's the it's like labels is like still
like they catching up you feel me but
it's like they still kind of stuck in
that old stigma whereas they're like
it's like a
i don't want to put it in
i don't know how to say it's like
the deals were so shitty back then you
feel me and they still like try to
implement that [ __ ] now like we still in
those times and they'd be like bro we're
not we streaming now and [ __ ] like it
ain't i mean people ain't going to the
store and buying no [ __ ] cds and [ __ ]
no more [ __ ] over but they still got the
deal kind of structure like that you
feel me and it's like why the [ __ ] if
y'all can catch up with the money on the
streets why the [ __ ] y'all can't catch
up with the deals you feel me like that
[ __ ] don't be making sense to me and
they'd be like
once you learn it as an artist
that should be like kind of like scary
for a label they'd be like damn [ __ ]
asking too many questions right like
we gonna figure it out there try to
start you out you know what i'm saying
but it's like
artists are getting smarter right and
then we'd like to look at like the like
i always look at someone like russ and i
feel like russ gives out so much free
game to artists
right just like i talked to
he i always anytime i think like
something like i can't get this [ __ ] i
don't know what the [ __ ] i hit that
[ __ ] like yo what you think about this
bro
hey really like give me the whole
paragraph bro like how i should do this
[ __ ] somebody said i could agree with
somebody should be like i could take
that and i do how i'm doing do it your
way yeah hell yeah but that [ __ ]
different he's smart bro i feel like the
labels hate rust cause he'd be really
[ __ ] holding their feet over the
[ __ ] fire
he popped his [ __ ] and it's all real
lawyers hate him because he's like yo if
you're giving your lawyer ten percent
they're hoeing you ain't real [ __ ]
that's your offer that's bro when i
finally got to know the business because
you like when you come into this [ __ ]
bro you're like i see it all the time
like you just having fun you just so
like
you want everybody else to do your [ __ ]
cause you want for like i don't want i
don't want to have to be the [ __ ] to
book my own shows i don't want to have
to be the [ __ ] to
be looking through these emails just
decipher this [ __ ] the serious about
this feature right right right right
trying to make music right now i don't
want no no and you will put this on
everybody like huh you do this
you get it you do this you feel me but
that [ __ ] be like
you got to know your business bro you
got to know what the [ __ ] going on you
got to know everything that's going on
with you this is your [ __ ] you know what
i'm saying at the end of the day like
it's cool to have people that
a team you need a team but you got to
still be on your [ __ ] you got to know
what the [ __ ] is coming through these
emails who person like you got to know
the same people that this person you
don't want to be just having people make
connections through you but you're not
even meeting the people you know what
i'm saying right now everybody building
relationships with nobody you don't even
[ __ ] know these people
that should be different bro you gotta
you're you're dropping a new project on
thursday night yeah my glow day
is that your birthday oh yeah it's sad
the ninth is your birthday yeah oh it's
my anniversary my wedding anniversary
hey
that's just how i'm feeling right now
thursday's a big day kanye drake you got
their show in l.a thursday your birthday
you got an album coming out i heard
their ticket was like 7500 or something
probably i'm not going to be there so i
wouldn't know but nonetheless
i i'm always curious if someone like you
do you feel like if you were independent
the last
three to four years how much more music
would you have
dropped bro what
i got like and my phone is saying my
email my hard drive i probably got like
over like 2 000 songs that nobody ever
heard type c cuz is it that much more
harder if like you woke up tomorrow and
said i got a [ __ ] ep with this
producer i've been cooking up with this
whole week and it's crazy and i'm trying
to drop this [ __ ] right it's not that
easy [ __ ] no bro i can't even say i want
to put this [ __ ] on youtube real quick
oh vlog you know what i'm saying because
they got my youtube you know what i'm
saying i don't even got access to my
[ __ ] so you don't even have access to
your own youtube [ __ ] no bro when i got
somebody take over all your [ __ ] they
actually all these questions like all
right which password to this uh do you
ever got to account over here we need to
password to this you'll be thinking like
are they just going to have access to it
but they tame they changed your whole
[ __ ] over here like they need to reroute
my money i don't even get my youtube
check anymore so you can't
drop a video tomorrow or a vlog [ __ ] you
got to send this to the label first oh
yeah what the [ __ ] and it's like it's
cool because i like how labels i like
what i it's a it's a i gotta love it
it's a gift and a curse yeah hell yeah
they do what they now at this point in
time my label was only [ __ ] you know
what i'm saying like they take care of
everything they're supposed to do
because i didn't got too smart you know
what i'm saying like i didn't figure
this [ __ ] out and it's like we was at
eyes for a long time we came to a mutual
agreement it's like all right boom we
finally
thank you you know what i'm saying like
appreciate it you know i'm saying i was
i was feeling sour for a long time and
now i was like i'm back i'm back in my
yeah i mean like i feel like you had a
couple of records that
should have probably been a little
bigger like you know i think i thought i
was expecting the nikki murder beats
record to kind of go crazy they was mad
that we even wanted to drop that [ __ ]
because they felt like they wanted to
ride the trap started turned pop started
wave a little bit more like i ain't i
wasn't i wasn't too pressed to drop that
[ __ ] even though to be honest because i
was working on a whole tape with murder
beats and i wanted that to be like a big
roll out i wanted that to be the part of
the rollout but at the time my
management was just like we need to drop
this [ __ ] now like nikki [ __ ] nikki i'm
like all right [ __ ] it you feel me
he just was like
be pressing the button too early that's
fair wait hold on time to stop the
interview because we got to talk about
our good folks at odd socks man listen
if you go to
oddssoxoficial.com that's
oddsoxofficial.com
use the keyword keyword it's a [ __ ]
promo code use the [ __ ] promo code
bootleg kev all right at checkout you'll
save 20 off they got i mean look at
these spongebob joints
man the ninja turtle boys you know what
i'm saying how about the naruto guys
and then they got the new odd socks
basics that are just like
they're just so fly man the tie-dye
joints they just listen man
whatever you need they got it how about
some half-baked boys you know what i'm
saying listen the most comfortable socks
the most affordable socks the best socks
in the world odd socks so go to
oddssocksofficial.com
use that keyword it's not a keyword it's
a [ __ ] promo code
[ __ ]
bootleg kev at checkout save 20 off man
shout out to our family at odd socks if
you support us go support them um
i think about
bef before you move to la
i remember i saw you right after you
decided to move out here and i was like
good because i felt like
there was a period of time where every
time i would open my phone
it was just some [ __ ]
b and b rock was just in some [ __ ] i'm
like
what the [ __ ] yeah i'm like this
[ __ ]
you're wild you know what i'm saying
like i got out of this [ __ ] i was gonna
say like um
i feel like you've matured a lot
in the last couple of years as far as
maybe
keeping yourself out of unnecessary
situations that might bring unnecessary
[ __ ] around do you feel the same way
oh yeah i got two daughters now you know
what i'm saying and
i ain't only that [ __ ] just
tired of that street [ __ ] you know what
i'm saying get burnt out bro
that's just tiring bro stressful [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] you don't have to keep like
looking over your shoulder everyday i
had and philly that [ __ ] bad right now
bro that's just super super big like we
probably got like
how many mergers we have right now tyler
and philly
500 over 500 and overlapping five to six
months
it's been mostly females getting killed
by [ __ ] like literally what some weird
[ __ ] [ __ ] is like domestic violence [ __ ]
a lot of it been the domestic violence a
lot of been like [ __ ] like [ __ ]
just killing [ __ ] i don't know what
the [ __ ] it is like i seen some [ __ ]
where somebody thought it was like
i don't want to be putting this [ __ ] out
there so i ain't even going to say [ __ ]
i talk about you right
right that should be weird though bro
well it's interesting too because like
we just we just lost
dolph and dolph was you know i had a
great relationship with dolph he was a
great guy but
we keep seeing artists losing their life
in their hometown
right wicked um
happened happened in nipsey happened to
x um
i feel like it's almost necessary to
kind of remove yourself out of
your own environment for your own good
really for your own livelihood you know
what i'm saying [ __ ]
got to
be like people love you the most in your
city but but they hate you the most
there too
like you got some [ __ ] that just
really likes
i see i remember that [ __ ] when he was
broke now he think he uh
like [ __ ] we just don't want to see
you win for some reason some people got
that crab in the barrel mentality like
[ __ ] you i'm stuck you gotta be stuck
with me type [ __ ] like on someone
when you see like a situation with dolph
you know or nip does it help does it
kind of
change the way you move
hell yeah before you didn't
the nipsey [ __ ] was crazy
i think the first journal for me though
was like
looks like something from pittsburgh or
some [ __ ] oh um
jose uh was it the guapo the guy who
died he died the same day as nip yeah
yeah he died the same day it was the
same day damn so yeah i heard about that
first and i'm like damn this
[ __ ] like he was close to philly
in pittsburgh's night right there yeah
it's far but like we on the same type of
[ __ ] kind of like you know what i'm
saying like i'm like damn that was a bad
joke for the city you know what i'm
saying the pittsburgh i'm like that
[ __ ] was still in the trenches he's
kind of just like me like
that was like an eye-opening like thing
i need to
get away from you it is just in general
i feel like crazy right now especially i
mean we both live here in la and la is
[ __ ]
wild
crazy
there's some grand theft auto [ __ ] going
on right now [ __ ] bro you seen that [ __ ]
with a [ __ ] just walked up in the
restaurant
yeah bro that [ __ ] was goofy to me yeah
i tell my well first of all
i'll be in the valley so
me and my wife keep it super low key but
i tell my wife when we go out to eat i'm
like leave your she got a big-ass
wedding ring i'm like leave that [ __ ] at
the crib i don't even want to kill you
though bro you know what unless you're
gonna move around with security you
don't wanna have to do that where did
you get the time you go out a hundred
percent feel me like that should be ass
bro
i feel you people are targets out here
and especially
a couple times you feel me like i ain't
gonna lie that [ __ ] don't never work for
me i'll be too on point like i'm from
the same [ __ ] y'all trying to do i
didn't did this [ __ ] you feel me like i
don't know you're ready for that kind of
[ __ ] yeah yeah i'll be on it
that's fair that's fair i think like a
lot of people need to understand when
they come to l.a
don't think this is a joke well
yeah but like yo man leave your [ __ ]
jewelry in the hotel room or just leave
it at home like there's no reason for
you to move around with a hundred
thousand dollars worth of if you're
gonna do that [ __ ] bro be safe be safe
get some security yeah
like i ain't going to see her and say
security is like a endo be a [ __ ] ain't
going to try you but it's thick twice
don't think twice about trying you yeah
hell yeah 100 it just makes sense you
know it does man um
talk about
you know obviously
you
being a part um and working with sao for
people who don't know sal is
exo the weeknd i mean doja cat i mean
just
superstar management yeah i ain't gonna
lie they put me on a whole bunch of game
shout out to my guy manny
um
what what is something that you've
learned
uh
being so close to
them because i do feel like
there's something to be said that like
right now like sal and company
represents
two of the top like three or four
biggest artists in the world
or they mean there's a lot of people
that people they i mean they managed to
dollar sign they can go down the list
but i'm just thinking you know much
[ __ ] like so many right shout
out to my brother belly shout out to you
know yourself shout out to you know
it's bb rex uh it's just so many artists
right so crazy cat but that's just like
another level of [ __ ] right when we get
into the conversations of the weekend
and you know like like what's the [ __ ]
you've learned about being a part of
that team i don't know i just learned
like structure like that when i went
over there i just learned like
they told me like
when i come to album time and [ __ ] like
that like as far as packaging my [ __ ]
they put me on a whole bunch of game
like how they be doing a [ __ ] you feel
me
and
they told me a lot of [ __ ] about my deal
because when i first got with them that
was like one of the main things that i
was like focusing on like yo i need
y'all to help me get me out this
[ __ ] this deal that i made you feel
me like this [ __ ] ain't it right it was
like they was helping me a whole bunch
with this [ __ ] i really learned a lot
just [ __ ] with them on that but for
me like
they know what the [ __ ] they doing over
there what is um if if there's an up and
coming artist with some some momentum
right now that's independent what would
be your advice to them
as far as what they should do should
they sign should they stay independent
like what do you think i know not
everyone's case is the same right but
like you know based on your experience
easy [ __ ] for the kids bro like it's
like
you get your [ __ ] popping on if it
depends you can go either way like if
you really want to go and sign to a
label you feel like you need to do this
do it but just make sure you don't got
one of those like crazy ass routine
recruitment dudes you know what i'm
saying you looking for damn what's the
[ __ ] name was this i just i just
forgot the name of the deal
so you got
uh you got royalty deals and you got
it's two different type of deals bro i
can't think of the name of it because
you don't want no royalty though just
tell them you don't want to [ __ ] what
about on the pub side because you're
obviously a prolific writer
and i do feel like the pub game also has
evolved a lot
because there used to be the mda was it
the md mdra the minimum delivery
requirement joints where you had to have
like a certain amount of [ __ ]
points accumulated before you could get
out of a pub deal so we would hear about
these crazy ass pub deals where like you
had to have five full compositions but
that would mean five
500 points yeah i don't even understand
this because if you write a record right
you might get like
if you help on a line right let's say
you're
you might get what you know i don't know
whatever points that might be but it's
definitely not going to be a hundred so
it almost makes it almost impossible for
you to like actually fulfill the deal
yeah that should be goofy bro the way
that [ __ ] work points is like i ain't
know what a point was for a long ass
time right
i used to be like you could have a point
i don't give a [ __ ] about no point like
taking like no percentage of all that
you you could have a point points is
like percentages at the end of the day
same [ __ ] so in points so
in deals you got
100 points right you say that
you might get a deal where you the label
give give you 15 points and they get the
85 you feel me and that's after you
recoup no hell that should be crazy so
it'd be like
out of that 15
all the bills was going to come out that
15. yeah like all the studio time well
they're going to give you an advance and
then that advances in advance on your 15
exactly so whatever you spend out of and
then whatever you spend out of your
budget comes out of that 15
and then the 85 they take free and clear
for sure and then we'll [ __ ] you up even
more though is these points that you'll
be saying like oh you can have a point
because you're a producer you did this
or you could have a point because you
mixed it are you helping the line or
whatever so you go from 15 points you
gave him two points now you had 13.
right right
the line then you're like [ __ ] 12.
and then that [ __ ] go down you like look
at you like 10 points and it's like now
all the money coming out of this 10
points
what the [ __ ] i thought i had 15 points
that should be crazy probably like that
should get tricky that's why like when
artists take those big advances like
they really should try to make them last
because you have no i like you know what
i'm saying like i don't tell you about
none of that [ __ ] right
you [ __ ] broke you don't got nobody
around you that got no money neither so
you're the only [ __ ] with money
everybody looking at you now that [ __ ]
be crazy like damn i don't even got no
money money literacy like i don't even
know what to do with this [ __ ] right
right right right
you uh this new project coming out on
your birthday who else on it
my birthday thug a little baby
i mean [ __ ] that's it there it is
there it is no kizzy that's all you i
mean and then this project wasn't even
supposed to come out i ain't gonna lie
to [ __ ] i'm forcing it right now i
wanted to give people something at the
end of the year like to
because people been begging me for music
i haven't dropped the album like damn
near three years you feel me it's like
i know i know that i can't just keep not
dropping because what trap starter in
pop star was 2019 yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah i mean we're about to be in 2022.
[ __ ] that's some real [ __ ] so i was like
i like i'm gonna give y'all a gift my
birthday for my birthday i'm gonna give
y'all a gift for me i'm gonna get y'all
six smashes that i've been having now
it's gonna these songs was gonna go on
my album to be honest but i i wanna give
like a preview to the album for me so
whatever songs take off on this they
gonna definitely be on the album they
don't
put some new [ __ ] on there for me but i
just wanted to give something to my fans
this is called to get you through the
rain to really get y'all through the
rain i know y'all tired of hearing all
these little pnbs i've been begging me
for [ __ ]
and go a little six people the little
pnb's is out here no kids they're
definitely out here i'll be peeping you
for me whatever my [ __ ] with because i
understand them but some of them is like
you just totally just taking a whole
[ __ ] sound is like brushing ain't gonna
work i do feel like you didn't you and
rod wave have a little weird moment
online oh my god yeah we definitely had
a little weird moment i was trying like
i hit him up a few times on something
like yo i'm [ __ ] with your [ __ ] you
feel me like
right on this page type [ __ ] dm'd him he
he
i guess he ain't see it you feel me
but
then i like posted like a little video
of me like singing one of his songs and
[ __ ] that [ __ ] kind of went viral like i
took that [ __ ] down though because i was
fun like like i was just on some like
doing too much you feel me like right
this [ __ ] ain't really like [ __ ]
with me like that right
but anyway long story short he had post
assumptions on there now he went crazy
everybody was like you don't [ __ ]
come to florida so he said some wild
[ __ ] i was like jesus christ that
escalated quickly so yeah i'm like hold
up i posted some [ __ ] on my instagram
and said like i'm so sick of this new
type of music like all this sad [ __ ]
y'all making me like too depressed right
now you know what i'm saying like i want
y'all to turn me back up you feel me
like
a very general statement that's a
general statement yeah i ain't saying no
need someone put the address on that
[ __ ] [ __ ]
i'm like hold that bro
no it escalated quickly it escalated i
don't do all that [ __ ] right right right
before i dm them you feel me like what's
up you [ __ ] like what's the word
you had some words and [ __ ] before me
and then he went on the internet again
and said some [ __ ] i'm like what are
they doing she must be trolling me or
something like the [ __ ] like
we already said what we had to say
already yeah you guys talk privately in
dm yeah that [ __ ] [ __ ] my brain up and
i'm like this [ __ ] must be trying to go
viral i guess this is mine i think it's
some young young dude [ __ ] too man
you know i feel like you know maybe at a
certain point in time in your life you
were in that mentality you know what i'm
saying i never really think about the
viral [ __ ] like not even that i just
mean just like i think a lot of people
when we're younger we just react
it effects without thinking because we
haven't we haven't lived enough life to
realize that's not how
you know in the same way that you're
like man i've dm someone now you know
what i'm saying but like as opposed to
like a 20 year old kid who's barely
getting famous
just take [ __ ]
went left it just went left like bro i
didn't say your name like what the [ __ ]
are we talking about like who are some
artists that you are fans of what
they're doing right now that are younger
that are kind of you know on the come up
right now
because i do feel like you have your ear
to the street and you have a great ear
oh yeah i'll be [ __ ] with all the
kids i got a couple of my own artists
i'm gonna name some of them first i [ __ ]
with this [ __ ] named mama cinco he's
from philly go crazy leaf war he from
philly he go crazy
um i got some kid named tennis from
jersey he's going crazy um i got a whole
bunch of ours i ain't gonna keep naming
my artists but some of these new artists
that y'all probably are gonna be
familiar with real soon i [ __ ] jumbo
named baby santana he [ __ ] with little
tekkas like one of the little tekker
artists okay [ __ ] with autumn his name
is autumn he's going crazy crazy right
now i just went to the show one of his
shows that [ __ ] had that [ __ ] like he
looked like one of us all right yeah
i [ __ ] with
um i'm so fago i [ __ ] with a whole bunch
of the young son there's an artist's
name i'm so fago yeah is he a juggler i
don't know i think i just said his
instagram name his oh my god
i think of faygo i think icp
i think insane clown posse
i'd be forgetting people use faygo for
for lean and [ __ ] yeah that's it
definitely the drinks when i was a kid
faygo was associated with the insane
clown posse and they used to shoot two
liters of phago into the crowd it was
[ __ ] great it was like a [ __ ]
white trash [ __ ] super show
lots of mountain dew faygo and cargo
shorts and vo i never even knew what
figa was until i came out here really
it's a detroit soda company they're
based in detroit yeah it's crazy yo it's
great you know you and i like i said the
last time i uh really well i'd seen you
a few times but
when i when i pulled up on on you and
young blue working at uh at the crib
young blue someone you know who who's
been doing this thing for some years but
has finally kind of cut through
um
also kind of coming from that same
background of
blurring the lines between
the street soul [ __ ] i guess
how dope is it to see someone like him
you know like i feel like blue's on a
run right now and
[ __ ] yeah absolutely i told him when i
first first started seeing it i hit him
up like
it's starting to come because people
don't realize he's like he's not really
a new artist he's been doing his thing
for
five six years yeah he got a fan base
they've been rocking with his [ __ ]
he's been having millions and millions
of streams hundred percent like ben had
plaques too yeah real [ __ ] independently
yeah on some [ __ ] so
for me to see him it's just like give me
like hope that i could still catch my
second man you got it bro it should you
just gotta drop just keep dropping oh
i'm definitely about to start dropping
that's what my whole plan right now is
to just flood the flood the market bro
100
well look the first the first of that is
coming well it's going to be out your
breath by the time this comes out it'll
be out yeah thanks so go run that [ __ ]
up we'll run that [ __ ] up to
to get you through the rain i'll be i'm
afraid right now and i got some more
[ __ ] coming up today and some more [ __ ]
coming today and then some more [ __ ]
coming out today
there it is man all right yo shout out
to my guy pnb rock for pulling up you
already know it's the bullet head
podcast